criminy in the limelight Juliet Michaels
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the show
so you wrote some songs and you also
wrote issues that you're gonna do
perform for us here tonight in a very
special person um before you do I have
to ask you why why was that your keeper
why was that the one you wanted to do
yourself because all the other ones you
gave a game to other artists yeah so
I've always kind of put a little bit of
myself into everything that I've written
but issues was a very personal song I
had written it about a fight they had
had with my boyfriend at the time not
anymore
thank God and it was just so personal
that when it came time to give it to
somebody else I just couldn't I just
couldn't do it
so this this was also men the meaning
the idea was that you were to give it
away yeah and how did that feel for you
when you horrible just with this song
I've never done this I had never done
that before I'm a songwriter
I'm not precious about about my babies I
give them up for adoption all the damn
time so then then you were kind of
forced to move into the limelight yes
very quickly why didn't you do that
before I mean you had after all you had
some great songs I mean as you can see
I'm not a very confident person
I'm very awkward I read somewhere that
you have stay hormones
do you say fried no oh yeah
I think we all have yeah we hide it
don't we but how do you how do you how
do you treat your stage fright now like
how do you get rid of it oh I panic you
panic I'm trying to breathe myself out
of the panic and then I panic a little
bit more what do you I mean you should
be so proud of what you've written and
iam I'm very proud of what I've written
I have so much confidence in myself as a
writer because I've been doing it for
years and at this point I know that I
can write a song singing is very very
good
I mean be having this huge monster hit
for for a long time now yeah how have
you dealt with it how have you dealt
with your stage fright on the limelight
and it's not always easy there are
definitely days when I want to be like
hey I'm just gonna go the bathroom and
just leave I don't but I want to and
then there are days when it doesn't feel
as terrifying and you know I I try to
surround myself with really lovely
people that are super supportive even
when I do like the shittiest job they
are still what are your dreams is your
dream to be in big arenas big stadiums
or is it you sit in the studio and keep
writing world hits honestly I don't even
think about that my entire goal since I
started writing was always to build
connections with people even if they
couldn't see me I was still building a
connection with somebody and that's
always been the goal for me well this is
your job are you afraid that you you
know
copy someone are you afraid that this is
all this is too good it can't it can't
be mine I have had that before but I I
have a very weird musical dictionary for
pop music and I can usually sense when a
melody sounds a lot like something so if
that's the case then I'm like no we
can't do that it's this song and we'll
just kind of switch it and make it and
sometimes it comes out even better so we
were gonna hear issues now you're gonna
sing that for us
alas you didn't bring your violin no I
know it was being fixed yeah I was gonna
play a little little bit with you yeah I
know Vilas being fixed yeah what kind of
violin I mean those are extremely
expensive
no absolutely and historic was made in
1735 and actually was played by UD menu
and who was my greats and inspiration as
a child the guy you'll enjoy when I was
a small boy
it's he smiley it's his old violet that
I play on that yeah totally random me
that it turned out that way yeah but
anyway this is behind and I've been
playing around China for the last few
weeks and with all the climate change
and with different climates there you
know I go through the body needs to be
it's time to change destiny affects
everything needs to be checked out in
the works
[Applause]
[Music]
Julia the stage is yours thank you so
much hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe